let's get to hatred mail the favorite
part of the week for many people are not
in our audience the least favorite part
of the week for some hey tree it's at
least brace yourselves for the only
information that can successfully
penetrate a tin foil hats Patriot Man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom all right it is appearing once
again it is entering the political
lexicon and it's really only a tiny
recess of the Internet in terms of the
political lexicon it is that phrase once
again what phrase is it making an
appearance in this week's hatred mail
listen up and you will hear it no doubt
soy boy alerts ID thing punch this out
of these guy I knock out the tea soy
boys man my education is more important
than your show you look like a small soy
poisoned child wearing his dad's work
suit for fun oh no not this whiny homo
David Pakman again into Gen politics
media that's what this program is about
basically into gauge in politics media
and that's what it's been about and gosh
darn it that's what its gonna continue
being about you can give a middle finger
to the hey tree it's by using the coupon
code hey tree at 42 sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership if you use the coupon code
hatred for tea not only will you get 40%
off but a hatred will cry and that is a
very very exciting thing also quick note
now that we have our new apparel
manufacturers in place we are ready to
start taking audience created graphics
and turning them into t-shirts very very
quickly and an idea I had is some Trump
quote shirt design so if you can do if
you have some graphic design skills and
you're hearing this search out some
funny Trump quotes incorporate them into
some kind of graphic ideally with a
transparent background in
high-resolution vector
our format and send them to me david at
david pakman.com and we will I think be
able to very quickly put together some
nice designs for david pakman show
apparel anybody whose designs are
accepted gets a free couple of t-shirts
with their design on it on me
looking forward to those send amend ava
to david pakman.com